>> Gg: WHAT DID OBAMA KNO
OUT UFOs?
A NOVERNMENT REPT IS
KEEPINTHE UNIDENTIFIE IN
UNIDENTIFIEDLYINGOBJES.
U.S. OFFIALSAY THEOUND NO
EVIDENCE THA THE WRD THING
THAT FHTER PILS HAVE BEE
EING ARE ALIEN SCE CRAFT.
EY S THEY CAN RULE IT OUT
EIER.
WAY TO TAKE A STAND.
ON DEO,HE STRAN OPENS
MOD IN WAYS THA DEFD ON
AND PLUMMETED 40,000 MIL PER
HO.
UNDS LIKE CNN RATINGS.FORMER PR
WA RECENTLY ASK ABOUTHE
SUBJECT ON THE NION OF ALIENS
WERE PVING TO BEEAL.
HESSERTED THAT THERE WOULD BE
IMMEATE ARGUMEN LIK W NEED
TO SPEND ME MONEY ONEAPON
ANY RELIGIONS WOU P UP ANDWHO KN
WE WOULD G TO.
INRESTG.
ITIALS SAID NEF THE 120
INCIDENTS RE T WORK OFHE U.S. ME
NOTULED OUT RUSA OR CHA.
CHI SAYS THERE N
REONSIE, THEIR WOR I GOOD
ENOU FOR ME
KAT, Y TRI TO GET ABDUCD
ANDHEY DECLINED.
THEY A FAIRLY AUTE ABOUT
QUALIFY HUM LI.
I'M A QUALITY MAN.
IF I'MNOT, TT'S HUGE
REFLECON OYOUR JUDGMENT.
[LAUTER]SO I TNKHAT THE OHING IS
A THG.
ALIENS ARE PROBABLY OUT THERE,
MAYBE.
WHYOULDT THEREBE?
THEOVERNMENT SAY OH, MAE,
MAE T.THEYON'T KNO WHA THERE
>> Greg: THEYOULDN'T FIGUR
T VIRUS
WE'RE WED.OULD TT B WEIRD?
WE SUCK
EAKS AND GEEKS WAS CANCEED
BECAUSE ITOULDT COMPETE WITWHOA?
THEY'RE PROBABLY OUT THERE AND
N'TANT TO HANG OU
>> STILL DENDING JAMESFRANCO.
>> NOTT ALL.
YEARS AGO. S T OLD FOR HIM T
>> Greg: RFECT.
SO E, I WAN TO THR O MY
HAPPENS TO BE ALIEN LIFE FORMS
D TY'RE DELICIOUSND
NUTRITUS,T'S OUR
SPONSIBILITY T HARVE AND
EAT THEM BECAUSE WE EAT OUR FELS
WS, CCKEN AND LAMBS.
THEY'RE DECIOU IT'S ONS
TO EAT TH.
THAT IYEORY.
I THK THAT LIKE I WOU GOO
WAR OVER THIS THEO, JOE.
SO I DON'T KNO WHY I TALKING.
YOU HAVE BNABDUCTED
>> GREG ALIENS THINK'M
PRESENTATIVE O THEUMAN
RACE
JOKES ON TM.
I WOULD EAT AN ALFBURGER
YORE ON TO SOMETHING.
I QUESTIO IF EY DON'T KW
WHAT IT ISN?OW CAN THEY SAY
'S ALSNTERTING ONE DAY
WE'RE READIN FAUCI' E-MAILS
AND THEN IT' CHA'S UFO. >> Greg
DISTRACTION?
I TNK THEY'RE DISTRACNG
U FM THE ROBOTS.
THAT'S WHA ITHINK.I THINKHEY HAF
E SNT OF THE ROT.
WHENHE ROBOT INVASIONSTARTS
YO WON'T B PREPARE.>> IT'STRUE..
IF IT SN'TOR THEPACE ALIEN.
>>HISS MYUSBAND KIND OF
ING.I WOULDHINKHAT ONCE THEY
COME OUT A THEY LIK -- W
THK WE HAVE ALNS.
ABOUT THEALIENS FIND OUT
NO,ET'S WAT T ALIENS ON THE HIS.
THEYEIVING YOU ACTUAL
FOOTAGE OF TNGS YOU D'T KNOW
WHATT .
BUT IN T 13th CENTURY, TT
DI MIGHT HAVE BEEN A ALIE
YOU' LOOKING AT THAT INSTEAD.
GOES TO SHOW YOU WE THOUGHT
WOULD BEOEXTED.
PELE THINK WE'RE GOINGO AREA
.
THEYE TELLING YOU THEY'RE HER
NO ANDOBODY I BLINKING AN
EYE.
>> Gg: IIGUR ITOUT.
WHEN YOU SHE Os, THEY'RE
LIKELIPS IN A SIMULATION
TH SIMULATION IS CREATED BY
A.I.ROBOTS.
WE'RE JUS AIMULATION RUN BY
YOU NOTICE TOLESN THE
LIKE THE HOLES IN YOU VERY SOU
THAT I CAN E.
I CANEE YOUR HOLES, TOM.
>> I GET IT.
I UNDERSTAND
[LGHTE>> THIS SWS YOUOW LITTLE
POINT.
HAVE NEVER BEE IN TO ALIENS,
NEVE BELIEVE IN SCE M AND
NEVERIKE THE X FILES.
LIKE THE ALISRE HE. IT'S GOVERN
EY'RE HERE.
BELIE THE OPPOSITE.
I HE NEVER BELIED IN THE
RELY.
MY WKINGDEA ITHATF
ALIENSO IST, THEY'RE JERK
SCHOOL.T THEM OUT OF T
>> CANE GIVE A FEW EAHLINGS
UP?
OVER OTHE.  A COUPLE OFHEM
>>reg: THEEMOCRATIC PARTY.
GREG.  NICEEDEAT THER
>>reg: SERVE THA UP.
THE THING IS,HEY P OUT A
STATEMENTAYING NOBODYLY YOU
INGSWE'LL SOT THEM DO.
THEN S WT IT IS WHEN IS
SHOT DOWN
>>reg:YES.
WH IF IT'S THEUBBLE BOY?
THE BUBE BOY.